my name is Karen green I'm the librarian
for graphic novels here at Columbia
University I did absolutely brilliant
and insightful opening remarks yesterday
that I will not repeat but which will be
available online within a week or two so
I'm just going to do some very fast
housekeeping remarks and then turn
things over to our first panel but first
I want to thank Jeremy Dalbir and Danny
finger off here in the front row my
fellow organizers made this happen after
every panel there'll be a half-hour
break during which panelists will be at
the tables outside signings they'll be
books for sale through the Columbia
bookstore set up right next to the
signing table so just line up by books
get signings and enjoy so that'll last
for half an hour after the panel on the
signing table is a clipboard with a
mailing list signup sheet if you are
interested in coming to further events
about comics that we're going to hold
here at the Columbia University
Libraries please feel free to sign up
and I will make sure you know if you've
got a program the last two pages of the
program have lunch information for the
neighborhood there's a lunch break from
noon to 130 so go out and explore
Morningside Heights please don't use
flash if you want to take photographs
because it will be so painful for the
panelists and the moderators and we are
videotaping the fabulous vin is being
the back there doing video and there
will be video of all of these panels up
and available again as I say within a
couple of weeks so perhaps no holding
your phone over your head for video and
blocking the view of the folks behind
you I sound like a real librarian now
don't I and Shh
Shh bathrooms are down one flight women
that way men that way and there's water
fountains down there as well we've got
the twitter hashtag up there and the
event that you feel like tweeting some
people sniggered audibly when I said
that but I just figured I would tell you
so enjoy enjoy this beautiful space if
you have a chance to walk into the
Rotunda which is gorgeous do so this was
the original library of this campus
until we stripped out the space and had
to move across if you walk out the front
door and look across campus you'll see
beautiful butler library which is where
the graphic novel collection resides and
now Chris Clairmont's archives as well
so enjoy the rest of the day I'm going
to turn things over to Eddie Portnoy who
is going to take us through the first
panel enjoy hi thank you Karen thanks
for organizing Jeremy Danny thank you as
well I said great colloquia symposia
whatever you want to call it okay this
is a periodical New York and let me
first introduce the panelists we have to
your far right Lorne Weinstein she's a
cartoonist who according to her bio is
still recovering from having a baby
moving to the suburbs of New Jersey
which happened two years ago her comic
books include girls stories the goddess
of war and her work has been published
in Cramer's Oregon the ganzfeld an
anthology of graphic fiction and the
best American comics of 2007 and 2010
her work has also appeared in The New
York Times glamour and Hebe magazines
she's currently working on a sequel to
girls stories in her work can be seen at
Lauren Weinstein calm next to her is Ben
catcher his picture stories appear in
Metropolis magazine his new collection
of weekly strips the cardboard valise
was published by Pantheon books in 2011
his most recent music theater
collaboration with mark mulcahy up from
this
acts which ice on and which is great and
if you have an opportunity to see it you
should it was commissioned and premiered
at the Coleman center for scholars and
writers the New York Public Library and
at Lincoln Center in 2011 he was the
recipient of a Guggenheim Memorial
Foundation fellowship a MacArthur
Foundation fellowship was felt the
American Academy in Berlin and the
cullman center for scholars and writers
in New York Public Library he's an
associate professor at Parsons The New
School for Design in New York City next
to him is Emily flake she's an
illustrator and cartoonist her cartoons
have appeared in The New Yorker mad and
Canadian business which he refers to as
Canada's premier humor magazine is that
true and that is that is true isn't it
yeah oh yes I thank you that changes
everything her weekly strip her weekly
strip Lulu 8 ball has been collected
into two volumes she's the author of a
book called these things ain't gonna
smoke themselves she lives in Brooklyn
with her husband and small orange cat
and her work can be seen at a flake ago
go.com lastly to my left to your left
Irwin hasten the inevitable or when
hasten born in New York in 1918 he
started he started his comics career in
marvel mystery comics number four coke
reading the ferret he jumped to DC in
1940 drawing the original green lantern
and creating Wildcat with Bill Finger
for sensation comics number one and also
worked on Justice Society and Wonder
Woman comics I in 1955 he created he
co-created the classic dundee newspaper
comic which ran for more than 30 years
hasten has taught it to Joe Kubert
school for cartooning for 25 years he's
the subject of a fascinating documentary
Irwin a New York story and his graphic
novel memoir lover boy was released in
2010 by vanguard publishing so please
welcome them and
we will get started as soon as I figure
out how to do this okay these are sort
of supposed to scroll not this is so
different from begin ok they're supposed
to scroll through but I'm not sure if
that's gonna actually work ok um dr.
school I don't have to do anything ok I
just had a few brief opening remarks uh
this is about New York and its
periodical press and its relationship to
cartoons obviously cartoons wouldn't
exist without the medium of the
periodical press and I just wanted to
make a few historical remarks for the
first half of the 19th century there
were really few very few images in you
in in American newspapers as printing
technologies improved just prior to the
Civil War publishers began to include
more visual imagery these images as
historian good their bars observed
appealed to what he called the
distracted reader or readers who found
the usual full pages of text broken up
with images much more appealing and
accessible this phenomenon expanded
readership and by the 1880s images were
a common feature of newspapers cartoons
especially political cartoons had also
become a common and often appeared on
front pages magazines like puck and
judge proffered numerous gag cartoons in
every issue in 1895 the yellow kid
widely regarded as the first comic strip
even though it really isn't a comic
strip it's not I'm going to say it's a
big single panel it's uh I that began
appearing and phenomena notice the
comics exploded Sunday funny pages were
born giving way to the daily funny pages
cartoons would become a regular feature
of the periodical press for over a
hundred years they would also produce
the major offshoot of comic books and
eventually the Underground's and the
major center of this was New York City
now what's interesting about this
particular panel is we have generally
generationally we have a wide array of
people so I'd really like to start with
Erwin because I think he may be the only
one who the only one of an age that
worked at a newspaper or spent time in a
newspaper office I this is something
that really essentially has disappeared
because I think most cartoonists work at
home or in studios so I'd like everyone
to answer the question but everyone I'd
like to start with you other than just
you to describe how you got into car
tuning and whether or not being in New
York had anything to do with that I'm
awfully sorry but all my life I wanted
to be an entertainer and at my age now I
can hear the sound of a lot of the
voices but I want to tell you something
I'll never forget the sound of clapping
you've made me say that because I wanted
to say something very smart you know
exciting but I did indeed wanted to be
an entertainer first and I saw I'm in
the book of dewitt clinton high school
is a picture of me I can't believe it
because that's where I went to school
and I used to live around the corner
from this College this university many
many years ago on a hundred and tenth
Street and I always used to look at this
big building as a little kid and I said
what's up there on that Street on a
hundred a hundred sixteenth Street or
whatever and I now I finally made it and
thank you so much for having me here and
as long as I don't have to answer
questions do mine no I can answer
questions you're one button lower one
I'm the question I'd like it in sorry
everyone scrap mccreight the question
I'd like you to answer is how you got
into car tuning and whether or not
living in New York had anything to do
with that wake up ok here take them on
the question is how you got into car
tuning and whether or not living in New
York City had anything to do with that I
think I think and live and choose me
living in New York City and then being a
cartoonist has nothing there are the
great cartoonist who came from the
Middle West and little towns all over
the country nothing adored New York
nothing about the atmosphere of the Sun
had great bars
and they still do certainly do what else
so so new it growing up in New York City
being surrounded by you know I assume at
some point you went to art school I went
to art school I went to the national
academy of design which was one of the
great art schools of all the world in
those days old fashioned okay so did you
go to the National Academy of Design
Academy designer wait tube to the
students lame but did you do it to
become a cartoonist No ok so my mother
wanted me to be an artist she didn't
know what the hell I was doing I was
drawing pictures in the back of books
and she saw that and we this was during
the Depression we didn't have any money
we lost money we were rich we were
actually wealthy lost everything and
that's the worst part having it losing
it and we had to live phantom mountain
almost but we had a lot of class and my
mother took me to the school and
enrolled me and I said to her mom where
you're getting the money she said don't
worry just go be an artist and I was an
artist I learned how to draw not
cartoons and then I went to the Art
Students League and I met the most
gorgeous people in the world cartoonist
who wanted to be artists so the question
is why am I talking about being an actor
that wasn't the question there was no
question I invented it I think I wanted
to be an act
an entertainer because I wanted to be
loved that's an answer okay that's all
about okay love me let me get up on the
stage and I'll make you laugh I'll make
you laugh and that's what all these
entertainers you see now what's all
about okay Irwin felt so great let's
let's spread some of this love um Emily
can you can you address that same
question you know what as far as whether
or not being in New York has like if
that if that it all plays a role if the
same question for me as far as how I got
into car tuning or either or if it's had
it you know any effect in your life uh I
did not have the privilege of growing up
in New York so in terms of how that
affected me I grew up in your Hartford
which is that's that nowhere near is
good yeah it's a really long walk and I
was an exceptionally lazy child as so um
you know I I think in some ways you know
not growing up in New York gives you
sort of a fantasy life about what it's
like to live in a big city and you know
it gives you something to aspire to and
it it gives you I think necessary
dissatisfaction with your place that
also makes you become an artist because
it makes you fantasize it makes you
think about how you know how your life
could be different and better so I think
that was that was more instructive than
anything else in terms of how it became
a cartoonist and yeah I too started
making funny pictures because I want
people to like me assume i'm on the
panel yeah
somebody should have told me see I have
a sign and everything I'm entertained I
ok so so Ben could you address the same
I think growing up in New York actually
was an age it's an edge that we were
lucky I was lucky to live in New York
well I been gypped that thank God one
thing I did in my life if you want to
hear about it nothing serious I went out
with a lot of late ladies I loved women
and I was this big but the greatest
thing i did was to travel all over the
world I can say that when I would attack
labeija my parents never went anywhere
they came from nursery and they didn't
go back ok but they never traveled they
went up to the Alps the Jewish shops the
Catskills attachments take me they take
me there and I would draw a newspaper
cartoons for them but where I got the
idea and they should go for everybody
traveling around the world for a little
kid from New York City I was the
luckiest person in the world to be able
to do it to be able to go there so i
don't i'm sorry i didn't that's ok all
right Ben sorry go ahead um Oh what was
a bad i'm trying to remember what this
go about how New York effect well I am
you know the the periodical press by the
time I got into it was a kind of
bro you know there were only a couple of
papers in New York City and only a
couple of weekly papers so it was you
know babe but still maybe one more than
they would have been if Ike lived in
providence rhode island so you know I
had that that was the reality somebody
would come to New York to start up a new
weekly paper and that's how that's yeah
that could have that happened in New
York I suppose it could have happened in
other cities but you know it was once a
little wider field and it became a very
narrow you know monopoly to have a
newspaper you needed some money you need
they were not yeah by you know my
childhood there were just a handful left
and then the weekly thing the voice
dominated the weekly paper market and
then there was this thing the New York
Press started but I mean after these
underground papers that were talked
about yesterday but you know there was
enough media here so that you could the
odds of getting a strip in one of those
papers was probably a little higher than
in a smaller city right that's that's
all that's the only way magazines we
also had great magazines yeah things
like that yeah I don't know i think most
i don't know what this the statistics
are how many magazines are out of New
York as opposed to the rest of the
country its pages hey everyone read and
those days the Congress on the 18 what
the comic books the comics I'm sorry by
samack strips and I said that's so those
are the biggest draws in newspapers were
the in weeklies it was the comics and
the horoscope and the sex advice column
everything else was of no interest to
most readers they did a lot of studies
market research studies I never read
books a lot of you people i'm sure read
books I never read books I wanted to be
on the stage be entertained read books
no but I did indeed find a couple a man
named stendhal I don't know if you ever
heard of that artist a writer he was a
very classical writer like all the great
writers of all time and I picked up that
book and I kept reading it I don't know
how by accident you make up these things
you get into those things how come
you're reading that that stuff that's
heavy stuff but I insisted and I think
that's part of all of us should insist I
just made a very nice statement thing
insist and I'm talking too much no no no
it's fine okay but let's get to Lauren
correct me all right all right look cuz
i havent talked about this in years
especially would really wonderful throw
but wait so sorry irwin loret Lord at
the end is take a look at the end and
you'll find Lauren it here I'm sorry so
that's what I'm talking to the right um
I actively avoided New York City when
I'm going pursuing an undergraduate
degree I knew I wanted to be an artist
and I thought I wanted to be a painter
and I actually got into Cooper Union but
I didn't go because I was scared of New
York I thought it would eat me alive and
I'm really glad i didn't and now i teach
at SVA and i'm glad i didn't i see what
those kids go through it's like they're
up against so much and i'm glad that i
didn't have my undergraduate experience
there i went to st. Louis and then when
I got to New York there was kind of a
little weekly paper Renaissance between
the voice and the new york press it
seemed like there was a really good
group in the late 90s of people getting
weekly strips and I actually did it's a
weird thing for me to be on this panel
because I've never been in a regular New
York periodical but I got my first job
in Seattle's this stranger where a lot
of new york press people like in Village
Voice people like Tony millionaire and
Sam Henderson and Kaz and they were all
on the stranger to and it's interesting
how that that weekly job was the best
car tuning training I could have ever
gotten because I was forced to just spit
something out every week and you get
just get better and better and also the
community of cartoonists was amazing
meeting all these different people that
have kept me working all these years and
but then 911 happened as another big
thing and then a lot of the budgets for
these papers were just scrapped so Hulk
like The Strangers comic page like a
couple months after 911 was done so that
was it you know and now I think a lot of
strips are moving onto the internet so
that's where to see him you know so
there's more of an but I think there's
still the community of cartoonists in
New York that really binds people
together right that interests me um the
this community of cartoonists what can
you describe what that is and how that
functions it keeps you working cuz like
there's not a lot that does sometimes
you know it's like just just knowing
that they're all these people that are
really like I i lived in on South fourth
street and in Williamsburg and like
right down the street from you was Ariel
schrag and Gabrielle Bell and we got
together every week to make comics that
like there was this group that start
with started called artists with
problems and we just go and draw and um
I you know recently had a kid moved out
to Jersey but I still keep in touch with
all those people and its really really
important
just to you know have those connections
I don't know right Ben Ben do you have a
similar situation or how did you when
when you're starting out they saw no I
think the great thing about comics and
newspapers was that the people who ended
up reading your strip were not
interested in comics as a form they were
looking for an apartment or looking at
the sports results and you didn't have
this you know people who had just drawn
just to the form and that's the only
place i found a readership in the comic
world I mean you know the taste of most
cartoonist would not connect with my
work and so that world didn't that was
not my audience so I'm sure there's some
cartoonists who enjoy your work yeah
yeah but I mean not you know the
mainstream comic world this this was not
the place this stuff could live so it
had to be in a newspaper right swear or
now in an architecture magazine with
people are you know interested in
architecture and it's it's a form that
you can talk about all these things and
it's not I don't think it's the form
itself that's particularly it's it's a
great form but it's a multimedia it's
like theater it's like movies it's not a
there's nothing intrinsically
interesting in that I mean that's a form
right so it's you know but I a community
now I mean all the people involved with
raw they a lot of them were in New York
were a fewer i don't even sell maybe
trying to think statistically but there
are cart i know cartoonists in New York
but um I did when you know when raw was
being publishing you were being
published our did you interact with the
people or did you just go and hand in
your strip and now we had a occasional
reason
to socialize but I can't say it was a
yeah more of a community like by long
distance we all knew we were in the
world working but not no not I wouldn't
say it was a story heavy social scene
like you're talking about right I know
oh sorry um Emily did you did you have
such an experience with you know sort of
a cartoonist community in New York or
elsewhere that that you know sort of
Primus like the idea of a cartoonist
community cuz it sounds like some sort
of like terrible calm you the plumbing
doesn't work at all but everybody's got
cool pens I yeah I mean I think you know
in a lot of ways it's it's it's great to
have it available to you you because
there are a lot of people working in
your field that you can sort of reach
out to ya curtain people hire car tuning
I mean just a dress for a second which
I've been doing all afternoon I heard
Stephen job on television the other day
and I realize how fortunate I was to
have lived in a world where there was no
jobs oh there's such a different spin
idea of what humor humor is about and
talking about you man talking about a
talking and I listen to this man and
exchange he wants to change the whole
spectrum of argot society that's when I
think that tells you what I'm all about
well we don't have to worry about him
anymore
I don't want us to go away okay good
call go ahead Emily that's what I see
okay or what or what again we're gonna
let Emily finish what she's saying and
then we'll come to you okay well Emily's
gonna finish what she was saying and
then we'll come to you okay I'm sorry oh
I'm so sorry oh yes sir it's just not
I'm sorry yeah but again it's just it's
having the availability of colleagues
but i think you know also it's just
important to have a place that's sort of
consistently stimulating to the extent
that you want it to be as New York is
you know like some a place where you can
just you know go out on the street and
you know just be you know inspired
visually that you this all the stories
on the streets cetera et cetera I think
that's a very important thing whether or
not you have like a technical community
around you I think just the energy of
the place itself is very important
that's all okay thanks Erwin the best
describe that event yeah if I may my
favorite cartoonist was a sports
cartoonist Willard Mullen most of you
have never heard of him and then there
was a man named Roy crane to me he was
the master let me tell you a quick story
he was the master buzz Sawyer was
history you people remember him know of
him he was the master pointed nose a
little mustache came from the south no
one ever saw him he'd come up to New
York and a convention one day I was
invited with a group of others I'll tap
I'm not a cartoonist to come to an order
to not just like this and when I was a
kid I read his strip this man Roy green
and I'm sitting there while i was doing
gandhi and he sat down and a gentleman
sat down next to me with a mustache and
me and all he did was go like this i
like the way you're doing it that to me
was the highlight of my life for the
rest of it one moment i like the way
you're doing it it wasn't Steven jobs
I'm getting a little mortal in now is
that the word Moreland that's a word
sorry forgive me today because I feel
like talking so go ahead okay um what
think I'm curious about is how how and
if at all New York City figures in your
work tell me away I'm sorry
how New York City figures in your work
if york city appears in your comics well
done d it was Danny came as an orphan
from Italy and he snuck aboard a ship
with his buddies from World War two got
out of a duffel bag and that's how it
started and I think that having him with
his grandmother multi-billionaire woman
etc that's though I don't know if you've
read dandy that was the basis of the
whole thing and it was a combination of
his little kid and the big world in the
big New York and a kid because all the
time Italian boy I happen to love deadly
I love easily by accident that's how the
strip started but I other than that yeah
i think that new york city was there a
milli I word who's a melting pot in
every sense of the word so that's about
what all i can tell you okay Emily um
can I'm so sorry we can't do this
without my throat it's okay Emily just
use how does New York figure in your
work I mean I wouldn't say that my work
has a particular New York locus per se I
mean except insofar as you know working
for The New Yorker yeah it's it's where
a lot of my work appears so I would say
the you know maybe sort of like uh
there's like a miasma of New York eNOS
you you owe me fifty cents I don't know
how to follow that
don't touch it here need some Purell
haha wow I just been shut up near
hartford hartford oh yeah home of the
smartest right dondi was in Buffalo
right I may have run into him that's
right there yes red yeah so yes general
miasma of New York eNOS with a Mei I try
to I try to hit a certain level of high
you know I was about to say I try to hit
a certain level of sophistication of
sophistication and my work but that's a
complete lie I I do a lot of fart jokes
I'm gonna I'm gonna pass that on I did
one strip called the Jew of New York
that was set in New York City in 1830
but and at a New York I didn't know and
very different than the New York I knew
but cannibal and most of my other strips
are set in a kind of reimagined city on
the east coast maybe of America but not
New York because I have there are a lot
of historians and sociologists have
written about New York and I didn't want
to get involved in that in those kind of
real discussions about the actual place
I wanted to rethink it so I gave you
know I didn't think it has a name and so
people who read it in Chicago said maybe
this is Chicago and people who read it
in Providence thought it was downtown
Providence so it's it's more about
looking at a large urban center of the
age of
they're a 19th century city but not the
I mean that's that's no place in New
York and in New York is all built and it
was all imagined on paper so that's what
you could do in a comic strip you can
reinvent the city make up your own
subcultures and your own newspapers you
know that thing that went up the daily
pigeon was a newspaper I invented a
cheap tabloid like the daily mirror and
I'm a and then there's a newspaper in
one of my books the evening combinator
is a newspaper that reported the dream
life of the city by some means they had
to get to report on people's dreams so
yeah it was a dream it was more of a min
imagined I city it is hot new york i
mean i did a the jew of New York is
specifically set on certain streets of
New York but in New York again I thought
I didn't know I just researched it so
that's weird right so so your your urban
setting is a kind of mythic well it's an
invention it's based on things that that
did exist in different places but also
some and other inventions right I find
it interesting because I think in a
certain way you're perceived as a very
New York no I don't know people read it
and assume that that I know something
about New York history I don't really
know but I know about the texture of a
city but I don't know much about the
specifics of New York history under your
culture even though I've lived here all
my life I just don't I mean I see me
know something yeah but not and I'm not
a I'm not a historian of New York
diamonds I'm sort of I know about my own
invented city but not the real thing so
it's a it's a and I think I you know
people mention in a metropolis and golf
all these fictional cities in comics and
they say well that's New York and I
don't think it is I think they're very
purposefully alternative visions of a
city in in a case of Superman you know
where Superman could exist and when the
fantastic the marvel comics that were
actually set in New York like Doctor
Strange and the Fantastic Four there was
coming very um it kind of in limiting
about that that they put it in the real
city even though weld it goes was kind
of am interesting but you know the kirby
new york city seemed a little sterile it
didn't look feel like New York to me
right that's so it's better to just you
know build your own city and go on from
there I think right okay Lauren I think
for me New York has always been this
amazingly multi-layered place that you
walk down the street and every single
block a million things happen in a
million ghosts live in this corner and
don't really know what happened but you
can feel it in some way and so I feel
like the times that I've used New York
and my comics like there's well that one
that's like the Williamsburg Bridge and
um I did that one I actually that's what
kind of its that's a bunch of bridges is
going on back of me up but uh I did that
one actually have to refer right then I
I did she sound the one at the end I i
made this great thanks um well so that
one I did when a friend commit suicide
um and so I I just did this comic about
I don't know like this feeling of like
these ghosts yeah and then the other one
I'm ready thank you thanks um then
there's one and it can keep flipping I
don't know if you'll be this one I did
is actually based on a park and
brookline massachusetts but I included
it because there's the city sorry
there's the city country you know like
that all these lives going on in a
public space all at once time passing
and things like that so the thing i did
and then in like dreams of and then this
one is directly based on places you
where you could still get a blowjob in
my rapidly gentrifying neighborhood like
this is just true like that wasn't there
was anything it's like exactly true um
and then this one that other word this
one was about being in Central Park and
seeing a guy that looked like the guy
that I was talking about before that
commit suicide I looked like that guy
and I don't know if you've ever had that
experience before where you see somebody
else and they just seem like they're
it's and this one's called borrow
borrowing your body and I just I feel
like public spaces are full of that you
always like look at all these these
people from these different you know
there who are I don't know that just the
experience you have a walking in Central
Park it's like this people have been
having this experience for years and
years of just people watching and it
triggering different plots and memories
and stuff so I want to say something
about your strip then because I you know
I read that involved in the Baltimore
City Paper in the 90s and I I think that
your strip more than you know any other
strip sort of formed my idea most of my
sort of fantasy life idea of New York
even that was never like explicitly
about New York just as it sort of formed
this vision of a place where decade sort
of collapsed in on each other you know
into this sort of like you know timeless
world and the site-specific weirdness of
New York you know it's a place where
like you know the soil has its own like
particular DNA and only thing you know
things happen here that can only happen
here you know I feel like that sort of
you know set the tone for what I thought
New York would would be like and then I
got here it was totally boring
yeah I love to be in strange cities so I
could the idea of having to construct a
strip every week about New York we just
just wouldn't interest me enough and so
I had to invent a place I didn't know
and I could sort of say what's around
this corner and you know yeah it's full
of specificity but it's not it's not you
know something a historian can now go
back to and say I spoke about this place
that was in New York I mean it's not it
doesn't work like that so it's um you
know d and I think all the fantasies of
urban life are just that somebody makes
them up and then some you know you you
either read about them or you experience
it yourself and anyway you know you only
know the New York that you know there's
a million New York's sure if you move in
the you know Dominican music circles
you're in some other world and if you
move in the Yiddish asst circles you go
to other places so there's not you know
it's such a dense place but I but anyway
but it should be it had to be like a
touristic pleasure for me every week
otherwise I would just feel very hemmed
in by you know having to talk about I be
I'd be competing with you know the
metropolitan section of the time so I
didn't want to do that but don't you
think like your work is I know it seems
almost like that that um that fictional
truth kind of thing like the essence of
the city like I would say like I don't
know I don't know yeah but it's not it's
people felt that about cities all over
the country yeah they said this is you
really captured downtown Providence and
I've never been there so you know it's a
fantasy it's its 19th century you know
industrial the end of the industrial era
that's what it's about and that's
it specifically kind of an East Coast I
wouldn't I don't think people out on the
west coast confused it's a nice color
Chicago Chicago they did yeah it ran in
Chicago people thought they said this
must be sure but but I mean why i
invented by own streets and my own
businesses because i specifically did
not want to talk about real thing things
when you talk about real things you
become a journalist and then you get
sort of involved with real people and
they and their reactions to it and I
mean fiction can just avoid all of that
and even on the grand Skyland we want to
be in New York sir but as a newcomer an
outsider to New York there's like the
the delightful and probability of all
the things that you see on the street is
very similar to the delightful and
probability of the things in your strip
you know so yeah and it that's it that's
urban life right you know 19th and even
late yeah 19th 20th century but that to
me and the thing is it's invent the
cities of man-made or human-made things
or their inventions and you can paper
reinvent it right and that's what
interests me
you know we focus the city and talk
about things on a level historian can't
even get to right internal idea I mean
all these things you can't you can't
discover as a historian or a sociologist
this sort of a limit right so the
fiction let you go into all these right
you just in very much place you've ever
invent your own okay should we take
questions yes but okay okay um we're
going to take questions now so if anyone
has some please step up to the mic go on
go ahead what actually can you step
through the bike because they want it
for the video
for question for Emily have you ever
done strips I'm familiar with your
cartoons but have you ever done strips
about a synth in the city or New York
City or other cities not really actually
I don't I don't I don't generally have
like a site-specific thing in my work
basically cuz I'm really bad at drawing
perspective so I try to keep it pretty
interior but no no not not not to not
any major extent okay and another to you
also I i recalled you mentioned you
lived in Argentina for a while what is
your way what was the vision in that
country of New York as a city oh I think
well in Buenos Aires there was there was
sort of like a sense of you know like oh
we're really where we're totally similar
like cuz I mean Argentina likes to sort
of pretend it's not in South America so
there was definitely a sense of like oh
we get each other because we're both big
cities ok but and there's a there's a
wonderful comic scene in Argentina
there's a lot of really amazing work
going on there and those artists
definitely look to the New York scene I
mean there's they're they're real
they're really into your work Lauren and
they I mean they love Chris where they
look you know they was not New York but
yeah yeah there's they have a very good
understanding of the new york comic
scene there but they're also you know if
any of you feel like checking it out and
or speak spanish it i get into it good
an observation from the two days as a
listener participant how eagerly
yesterday some panelists particularly in
the political one embraced the idea of
cartoonist comic artist his journalists
and why today it isn't embraced and I I
appreciate both points of view and it
occurs to me too that the impulse for
some to be a documentarian is one thing
and but the other impulse to be an
imaginative are
is something also so sorry just an
observation rather than a question but
if anybody would like to comment if
anybody pushes you in one direction or
another and why you might resist being
pushed and then for instance people
might think you're a documentarian but
you're not yeah oh I'm sorry but you
asking about why we went into it away
from journalism know instantly that the
the medium the form your work of the
many people who have appeared on the
panels embrace both being say a
documentarian journalist or being an
imaginative artist and as a fan of
comics I'm just grateful that both of
those are possible yeah well I think one
is the this more kind of utopian idea
that you can invent something that sits
beside the world as you see it so and
one wants to record the world you see it
is that you see in front of you so you
know that's I mean a lot of my strips in
in Metropolis are about things that
could exist in the world or should exist
but it just seems to be a lot of writing
about documenting the world it seems
very well documented so there's room for
that other kind of speculative fiction
and you know trying to look at
alternative worlds realities and so
that's yeah that's my impulse I thing
okay Danny I'm kerwin I know for your
generation kind of the ultimate thing to
have was a newspaper strip and hear what
is it better if I don't use the night
you know everyone I come come to him
yeah
come on come here come closer
for people of your generation to get a
newspaper strip that was sort of the
ultimate thing yes the Goldberg strip by
the way thank you for thank you for
interrupting mr. my silence the Goldberg
strip I got by accident I got out of the
army I had a wonderful stint in the army
because I I became alive again and I
became the editor of the newspaper Fort
Dix New Jersey and then I had a chance
to do the Goldbergs and the New York
Post was one of the first liberal
newspapers in the country and it was
Dorothy Thackeray owned it and I got a
chance to do the strip and I met the
most exciting woman I've ever met in my
life Gertrude burger I sure maybe some
of you heard of her brilliance and I did
the strip I did the drawing and I was
able to draw their the office Talon a
new worth street the New York Post and
this was just before franklin roosevelt
died and Gertrude and I became friends
she's a brilliant wonderful lady and I
met her secretary over the time and she
secretary called me this is very quick
story and she said Owen Gertrude's
having a birthday would you come down to
the hotel something forgot the name of
the hotel and join us for a drink and I
said my god are you king
the choose that she was a very big lady
in television at the time and we sat
down the three of us secretary and
myself and a young man comes in the door
from the street and she says Frank she
said Frank this is erwin hazen he's a
cartoonist or when this is frank sinatra
i give me shake hands and this and that
tall skinny young man just came over
from across town from the Paramount
Theater where he was praying to the
hundreds of girls all the young kids
that was another time I just had to
bring this a story up and so doctor
shook hands and said Jesus you know I
gotta run and she said I'll Frankie like
a mower Bronx a Bronx mother Frankie go
go and I'll never forget that moment
which I just had to let you see the
dichotomy of that woman from the Bronx
and Sumatra from Jersey City how they
got together how they got to be friends
at all you mrs. bloom and Frank Sinatra
my favorite all my life but I just had
to bring that up I'm sorry
I demand a diver because I'm sorry my
back my back is this beautiful drawings
I've never seen because that's the kind
of drawings I love and thank you girls
really I mean it cuz i was sitting here
looking at these Audrey faces I messages
kind of drawing that I'd love to do when
i'm not drawing oh that's all do you
have any more questions we've good what
do you say he wants to know what he is
that Jeffrey mmmm no I don't remember
them very often so I'm good a bad what
what my dreams are like no i don't i do
i know i do but i don't remember that i
miss you in conversation yeah i'm sorry
i rarely remember them and so and you
know i think that's it i never trained
myself to once in a while I do and
they're very um they don't have a
structure that make some of much use to
me I don't know they're these kind of
you know things I could make up in my
conscious life that they don't so I and
I often write when I'm just before i
fall asleep so I do I'm very conscious
of that half awake state and blue I'm
still able to think of stories but not
full dream it's a little out of my
control so I don't
I don't some reason I've never tried to
use dreams but ok last question please
to Irwin your are you aware of are you
aware of Dondi the graffiti artist and
do you feel your work has inspired his
eye I didn't say are you aware of Dondi
the graffiti artist I can't hate you yes
I heard of him I never met him the best
part of life kind of a story is i'm
sitting on a bus let's get avenue bus
and there was a little bit of college
boy running through this bus and his
mother said Donnie will you sit down
I'll never forget that daddy will you
sit down I didn't go over to her and say
that's my boy anyway I was better I'm
giving you a little tidbits cuz I can't
talk a lot ok all right thanks very much
please take our panel and
you